it is great to be joined today by Zoltan
Istvan who is a former journalist at
National Geographic author of the
best-selling science fiction novel the
transhumanist wager and now one of the
world's leading transhumanist someone
who wants to use technology in the
furthering of the next iteration of Homo
sapiens is that a fair way I just
finished reading Zoltan you've all her
Ari's homo Deus and that's sort of my
most general way of explaining what
humanism is am i close or how do you see
it oh it's definitely that I would say
that transhumanism is a little bit more
radical than that book basically we're
trying to merge flesh with machines so
we want to sort of evolve beyond the
biological I guess proportions of the
human being into something that's that's
trans human and when we talk about that
let's maybe before we get into the
details of what that might look like
what's the goal of that in other words
how does your understanding of what the
broader goal of homo sapiens as a
species should be lead to or translate
to transhumanism as the sort of path
forward well sure you know transhumanism
is just a social movement of now many
millions of people around the world and
we want to use science and technology
sort of as a number one goal to overcome
biological death and I think that's
really the main goal right now is this
idea that humans suffer is 150 thousand
people that die a day if you have
children they can die from leukemia we
all lose our parents and spouses and
things like that
transhumanist want to stop that and we
believe we can with science and
technology what are some of the ways in
which science and technology could do
that or or at least maybe the first ones
that you see is most likely well sure
within the next 10 years we're going to
have quite a bit of success I think and
probably the most important one is gonna
come from Bionic organs you know a third
of everybody you know will die from
heart disease and you know the heart is
just a pump so replicating it in a kind
of Bionic artificial heart is it's not
that difficult so there are companies
that are working on this right now there
are a few companies that have already
created them to some extent where they
actually
can electively replace your heart and
that way you could potentially kind of
stave off heart disease and things like
that but it's not just you know
artificial hearts because most people
die from organ failure
it's a bionic kidneys Bionic you know
livers Bionic lungs and things like that
so that's one of the best ways to do it
but of course there's genetic editing
where you can stop aging at the genetic
level
there's even crazy sci-fi things like
uploading your consciousness into some
type of machine so that your
consciousness could survive that way but
really you know staying kind of in
within science boundaries of the next
ten years bionics and probably reversing
aging through genetics are probably the
best winners so far of what how this is
gonna work talk a little bit about how
these technologies would sort of change
the perspective of Humanity on children
because in my mind it seems that right
now the current lifespan of humans and
the way sort of humans exist on earth
earth is directly connected with the
frequency and sort of timing and
dynamics and paradigm of how and when
people have children how do you see this
movement if it's successful impacting
how humans see the the birthing of
children well absolutely this is perhaps
the most you know fascinating topic and
I've come up with this concept called
delayed fertility advantage I mean it's
a very real thing right now that already
if you're a woman and you decide to wait
10 years you're going to have a
healthier child in ten years no matter
what happens just because of science and
in fact a 50 year old woman in 10 years
time will have a better chance of having
a healthy and safe child than a 25 year
old today so the entire dynamics of
giving birth and procreation fertility
are changing dramatically all because of
different types of Sciences that are
coming through the pipeline right now
that are allowing us to do this and this
is way beyond IVF this is different
types of you know actually taking skin
cells from your you know your hand let's
say your your cheek and converting them
into eggs or even into sperm and and
then mixing them in a test tube
having a child that way I mean in all
honesty we're are about 24 months away
from having children without having to
have any kind of partner doesn't matter
the gender doesn't matter the sex it's
just because we can make you know skells
from our own body now including sperm
and egg cells and so we're coming to an
incredibly bizarre era that will also be
complimented by the artificial womb
which the the FDA had done some pre
approvals on this kind of preemie bag
that would be there for you know babies
born in around 23 24 months they've been
doing them on lambs and now they're
trying to getting ready for human trials
at some point and we're entering almost
a matrix era and so this idea of even
having children within a 20-year horizon
might change dramatically because you
know if you can do all these different
things I guess the bigger question is do
you if you're going to live let's say
150 or 200 500 years do you even want to
have children and when would you want to
have children well you won't have them
when they're the most healthy and the
strongest and you have all these
designer baby things coming up like we
saw in China where the guy manipulated
the twins that came out just two weeks
ago so I mean we're entering such a
brave new era and I think it's going to
change our own relationships and culture
will people still get married when they
know they're gonna live a thousand years
I mean marriage is a lot longer in a
thousand years than the normal 40 or 50
so culturally it's it's gonna be a
paradigm shift so it's a place where the
devil's advocate a little bit what how
do we know that these are the areas that
humans should be focusing their energies
in right now and what I mean by that is
the following we have incredible degrees
of abject poverty in the world right now
less less than at previous times but
it's still an issue people are dying of
hunger people are still dying in parts
of the world of preventable communicable
disease a wealth and income inequality
are creating massive problems societally
psychologically problems of crime etc
etc and from everything you've said
which is a sci-fi fan myself
it all sounds fascinating and I'm super
interested in this stuff I have a hard
time making the case that that's the
right way to immediately focus
humanity's energy tell me why I'm wrong
well you're not wrong
to be
and I worry about this to someone who's
ran for you know a public office before
I think the big question at hand is
first off can we stop it you know I
understand that we would like to give
clean water and food to everybody on
planet earth and end poverty I mean I
want to do that as well but what's
driving a lot of these forces of radical
technology are not necessarily people's
desires but capitalism and as long as
capitalism is driving this train people
are going to continue to make new
advances and new innovations because
people can make money so whether it's
right or wrong isn't even that you know
I mean that's obviously an important
philosophical question but really these
things are coming about because Silicon
Valley thrives were a lot of this you
know a lot of these ideas are coming
from and where I live and they just
simply want to become wealthier the real
question those deep down how can we take
a lot of this technology and apply it to
mning it's going to be here because of
capitalistic reasons and apply it in a
way that actually lessens inequality you
know makes the world a better place
reduces poverty and all those things and
that's really when it comes down to I
think putting a lot of pressure on CEOs
on companies especially big tech
companies to say hey you have a more
than an obligation to just make money
your obligations to make this this
planet better so let's explore that
because as someone who correct me if I'm
wrong you identify politically as a
libertarian right you know I do that may
change but I will always probably have
quite a strong libertarian backbone fair
enough so in my mind when I think about
when we have previously said to CEOs hey
you know what you'd really better do the
right thing when Hillary quote went to
Wall Street and told them cut it out
right we heard that famous phrase
repeated over and over again during the
2016 campaign it hasn't really worked
super effectively so while I believe I
am a libertarian with these technologies
in the sense that I believe it's
inevitable that they are coming if
they're possible and thus we should
figure out how to make them work to our
advantage and to the greatest advantage
are you ready to say that regulation is
going to need to be a factor here if
they are not going to be technologies
that merely allow in a call
to grow to the point where you won't
have just wealth inequality and resource
inequality but you will have lifespan
inequality on the basis of what
technologies you can afford so I'm you
know as someone with libertarian
background I'm not willing to say that
uh I think the marketplace will allow
these technologies to develop and then
it'll be up to people themselves to you
know if this constant battle on Facebook
like Oh Facebook's doing this Facebook
doing up there's a really simple answer
for everybody on Facebook just stop
using it that's how you sync companies
and I think the same thing can be said
of a lot of these technologies if people
decide not to use a lot of these
technologies they won't have the
economic prowess to essentially survive
so I think the transhumanist age is
going to be born not only upon capitals
I mean it will appear because of
capitalism but it'll be because of
humanity chooses to go down that path or
not down that path especially in the
world of social media where we can kind
of immediately voice our sometimes our
opinions yeah but hold on a second let
me let me see if my cuz you I don't want
to get too past the far past the
argument you made if people don't like
the way it's going and then the free
they can operate in the free market to
punish that company customers can quit
like with Facebook whatever you could
say right now I mean Internet service
providers are one of the most disliked
companies in in and it's an industry
filled with disliked companies and the
argument you just made literally doesn't
work because they have legalized
monopolies right they have they have
legalized monopolies and if you are in
many parts of the country your choice is
okay fine I can quit but then I don't
have internet at all that is similar to
what could happen right so just saying
the market will figure it out it's
already not happening well I think
there's a big difference between telecom
companies and let's say something like
Facebook or technology companies that
would bring out an actual product
I agree we've legalized now the entire
telecom system so if you want to get on
to the internet you really only have one
or two choices and they're both under
the government's in the government's
back pocket but I think it could still a
lot of ways like let's say a company
brings out something like a brand new
way to have children in an art of
and everyone says okay this is the
designer baby age and only the rich can
afford it and you know at some point the
company wants to make this available to
the poor because they want to grow and I
don't mean poor but just anybody and at
that point everybody can say you know
what we're not gonna have a child that
ends up in a you know test-tube baby
because it ends up you know being
something different and we want to stop
this company which is you know creating
more inequality now that's what can be
done and that's the libertarian
perspective the problem though with that
is that if the majority of the world
chooses not to adapt some of these
radical technologies then you have a
generation of rich kids with higher IQs
correct everybody else then you run into
the situation but ultimately you know
I'm still gonna side with a lot of the
libertarian asks ideas where we need to
let this run its course but there are
methods that the rest of the world can
do to shut down companies I don't want
to go as far as regulation but if that
rest the world wants to pass regulation
and they can get it through Congress
then of course that's that's their
imperative yeah I mean I think here we
just district I think we've already seen
that this has failed we've seen that it
has failed on climate change we've seen
that it is failed with ISPs and it's we
can definitely say well those industries
are all different than what you're
talking about
because of this or that characteristic
but we may just not agree on that so
let's not get bogged down on it because
there are a lot of other things that
that I do want to get to when we talk a
little bit about the idea of
commoditizing
a life are you at all concerned that
some of the technologies that may be
available in the next 10 20 50 years
start to move life from something that
is sort of beyond markets and products
and services into somewhat of a
commodity is that a concern that you
have yes absolutely and I would be very
surprised just you know even as a
playwright area if capitalism survives
beyond 25 years so we're gonna be
entering into a very different space and
the reason I say that is because
automation robots are simply going to
take jobs and they're going to take
basically all jobs probably 98 99
percent of all jobs over the next 50
years certainly before the century is
out so we will have to develop economic
models that are totally different and
that economic model might mean that
humans have been commoditized to some
extent that we all take upgrades to our
bodies as almost in the same way cars do
but the greater picture is that humans
don't die from disease humans don't
suffer formalities we don't you know
we're not with the spectre of death is
not always haunting us the transhumance
age is really about eliminating
suffering so whether we're commoditized
or not is not the biggest issue I think
to most transhumanists what's the
biggest issue is that we don't lose
loved ones to disease and have to bury
them and for those of us who don't
believe in an afterlife that's the end
so it's you know this is a war against
aging in a war against biological death
whether we're commoditized or not
assuming that one can afford it of
course which was part of what we already
started sort of digging into and maybe
we'll talk about that a little more in
in part two of the interview we've been
speaking with Zoltan Istvan who is a
former journalist
at National Geographic author of the
science fiction novel the transhumanist
wager and one of the world's leading
humanists we'll continue our
conversation with him on tomorrow's
program we're continuing our
conversation today with Zoltan Istvan
who's a former journalist at National
Geographic author of the best-selling
science fiction novel the transhumanist
wager and one of the world's leading
transhumanists so maybe now we'll move a
little bit from the sort of societal
impact that we discussed in part one
into maybe some of the technologies and
paths forward I got questions from
followers on Twitter who want to know
about the bringing back to life of
people being cryogenically frozen
whether you agree or disagree with
Aubrey de grâce perspective unquote
curing aging what technologies you see
coming from CRISPR so maybe we'll start
very generally what do you see as the
most likely and promising specific
technologies to be first implemented
well you know cryonics is really the
only thing chronic is when you'd freeze
people and I've been to Alcor in Arizona
and you freeze people in hopes to bring
them back in thirty five fifty or a
hundred years and I absolutely think
that that's a viable science and a real
thing and I would do it if
knew I was gonna die of cancer tomorrow
but I think the real technologies that
everybody is hoping here for the next 10
20 30 years is probably using genetic
editing of some sort probably way beyond
CRISPR to reverse the way our cells age
and then to make it so that we can live
a lot longer and we have this kind of
term where if you can live one year now
you're going to gain another year in the
future based on how fast the trajectory
of life extension science is evolving so
it's critical over the next 10 or 15
years especially some older people in
your audience to try to stay alive
because we're at the cusp of a
revolution right now in the life
extension sciences we're very soon there
will be pills on the market that will
probably be somewhat functional making
you live a little bit longer and we'll
have Bionic organs that will be
routinely put into people and we'll have
different types of methods of just
simply keeping you alive longer and the
more the more length you can stay alive
if you can make it feel like 80 or 90
and I'm about 45 right now it's almost
guaranteed you're gonna make it a
thousand so it's really critical over
the next 20 or 30 years to try to stay
alive because all these coming
technologies so this this is the concept
I think that Aubrey de Grey describes is
the longevity escape velocity right that
once technology starts to develop more
quickly than aging takes its toll so to
speak every additional year you live
might give you a year in a week to live
or something like that and then you can
kind of extrapolate that out do you
agree that right now
aging is happening more quickly than the
development of new longevity science no
I think already today we're gaining that
extra year I think already that
principle of you know of the longevity
escape velocity is is happening right
now so it's it's and the reason I say
that is only because in the last 24 you
know maybe 36 months genetic editing has
so quickly changed the nature of
biological science where I mean it's
hard to overestimate how important
CRISPR and genetic editing technology is
this idea that we can kind of go in and
finally treat the human being as a
machine get in the building blocks of
DNA and reconfigure it it's safe to say
within 20 years we could be at the cusp
of a Star Wars era where
people will be growing a third eye on
the back of their head they'll be
growing a third and fourth limb they'll
be able to grow tails grow themselves
ten feet tall we're coming to an era
when we can really literally change the
way the biological structure is of the
human being and of course that will
allow us also to hopefully eliminate
most aspects of Aging so what why
haven't we seen that or I guess let me
ask you a different way
are there any data in which we see that
reflected because when I see you know
over the last five years we've not seen
a five year increase in life expectancy
or even in life expectancy at age five
which would account for infant mortality
so are there data that say what you're
saying which is that we already have
science outrunning the effects of aging
no no so right now it doesn't look like
that but I mean this is sort of an
extrapolation of just the next 10 to 15
years but the reality though is I mean
if you look okay unfortunately people in
America are dying more frequently than
before and less of a less age but a lot
of it has to do with obesity and this is
again gifts a very controversial topic
but if you look at overwhelmingly the
people that are wealthy and the people
that tend to keep good health of their
bodies they're living longer than ever
before and really the key there is to
stay healthy and try to stay skinny of
course that's probably the number one
thing and active as well as if you have
money for these types of treatments you
will live longer than ever before and
that's a statistical fact at this point
the problem though is that that doesn't
apply to a large amount of people and so
when we hear the statistics we think oh
America is dying more young than ever
well then you know we stop that trend of
continuing to extend our lifespan and
that's again when we get back to this
controversy where if you have the money
and you have the the proper trainers and
stuff like that you can live longer than
ever what do you make of the idea that
is out there that there is this sort of
ninety to a hundred and ten range as the
sort of natural maximum age for a human
body and I know that when we talk about
transhumanism you're starting to talk
about blending human bodies with
technology and that that makes them
beyond that do you agree with the sort
of starting point that 90 to 110 as even
if you can avoid particular acute
diseases even if you can
being run over by a car or whatever else
that that seems to be the sort of
natural maximum life for a for a human
body as it exists today you know that
sounds about right but you know of
course in the transhumanist age we're
not talking about anything natural I
mean with genetic editing we're talking
about restructuring the cell in itself
with you know transhumanism we're
talking about trying to eradicate eating
trying to eradicate drinking trying to
eradicate breathing air at all and with
a bio lung and things like that
I mean we're hoping in the next 25 years
maybe half of our body and this probably
is too optimistic but definitely the
next forty years half our body are close
to half our body would be entirely
synthetic part cyborg parts that don't
that last dramatically longer and don't
need nearly as much of the care that
biology does which is you know biology
is a system that's literally doomed to
age from the point it's every cell is
created to the point that it dies and we
want systems like a car where you could
really literally replace all the parts
so that you could continue on
indefinitely the biggest problem we're
gonna have is with the brain because we
don't understand the brain enough but
there is a good possibility that
definitely within 40 or 50 years we
might be able to augment the brain
through uploading you know consciousness
to some extent to machines or also just
through media a flurry and understand
exactly who we are through all these
different other elements and maybe a
combination of the brain or through stem
cell technology you know stem cell
technology who would have thought is
becoming one of the most promising
things where you can rejuvenate
virtually all parts of the body so there
that's the way that you would actually
try to stay alive
beyond that 1:10 age that might be a
limit of where you are as a human being
I think there's no limit but we must
treat the human being as like a car it
must be a machine to be constantly
maintained and updated you mentioned
stem cells are there any technologies or
directions that you think should not be
explored that should be off-limits for
moral reasons well you know the only
thing that I was saying this is quite
different than aging is I'm like many of
the other I guess
futurists out there I'm worried about AI
I understand the Terminator scenario and
I think creating an intelligence that's
smarter than us on planet earth is a
very very dangerous thing so I would say
let's stay away from AI but
there's nothing in the way of genetic
editing that I would say stop at all I
would say if we can increase our IQ if
we can make ourselves stronger taller if
we can change our are any color of our
skin we can change any color our eyes we
can do anything we want I would say 100%
do it if we can become something that's
unrecognizable to the human being but
more functional in the living world I
would say do it it's really only AI that
I'm a little bit skeptical of as a
technologist so let's talk about the
point of all this right an increased an
increasingly common discussion I have
with economists who talk about achieving
growth is let's break down why are we
talking about infinite and indefinite
growth as the target like why would that
be good let's defend that rather than
assume it and figure out how to do it
let's say that things go roughly the way
you're predicting or suggesting that
they might go humans have essentially
unlimited lifespans they're not immortal
but maybe they are immortal for all
intents and purposes we solve the a lot
of the issues that we're currently
dealing with the imagine whatever
scenario you want then what what then
becomes the sort of purpose or mission
of Homo sapiens in the universe well I
think we have to get rid of the Homo
sapiens I mean we have to understand
that we weren't Homo sapiens you know 2
million years ago and we're not gonna be
hope and say Homo sapiens in 500 years
we are an evolving trajectory of
intelligent life that somehow got very
lucky I think through an evolutionary
perspective and ended up here in Planet
Earth and 2018 and we're going to become
something different that's probably much
more machine light it's probably pure AI
where will be just ones and zeroes and I
think the AI age will only last 10 or 15
years because beyond that will be some
kind of quantum intelligence age or
something else I mean the whole
trajectory of the microprocessor
which is the basis of transhumanism is
that it's sort of Moore's law and mate
when motors law may not be you know 100
percent on there's no question that over
the last 50 years the microchip has you
know just been evolving and evolving and
evolving any faster and smaller and at
some point we become so accelerated in
technological development as entities
with that technology that we become a
totally different species so what's our
purpose right honestly I don't know that
and I
don't try to pretend to tell others what
that purpose is for me it's gonna be
maybe happiness and maybe even love with
my family even if that family is
consciousness uploaded into an AI but
one thing for is for sure dying a
biological death is not something that I
want to do or I would ever wish on
anyone else
so transhumanists as kind of a first
priority want to overcome that what's
the future maybe outer space travel and
all these other things
I don't know but certainly overcoming
biological death is really the main goal
of transhumanist right now will having
fun be a thing in the future if all of
this happens not 100% sure I'm not sure
if fun is really fun may have been
something from an evolutionary
perspective that we developed to make us
want to procreate and drink and have you
know enjoy ourselves but enjoying
ourselves might not be what a really
sophisticated entity that's maybe a
million times smarter than ourselves
when we're all jacked into AI or
something like this we'll want to do
maybe it'll be much more functional much
more meaning based I think it could be
very like even deeply spiritual in some
kind of strange way even though I'm a
secular person but something that would
be more based on pure meaning and being
driven to explore the universe maybe
curiosity I'm not sure fun is is really
hard or at what point does this ideology
become dogmatic in a way that's similar
to religious belief and I'm not saying
you know I'm not like I'm a
non-religious person myself and I don't
follow into the fall into the you know
atheism is a dogma just like religion
type of thing but when I hear you talk
about you know fun major simply not be a
thing and we're going to be able to have
meaning in ways that we can't even
necessarily conceive of right now there
is a sort of dogmatism I think you would
agree with a sort of idealization of
what this would be like oh there's no
question and if you talk to Christians
let's say about transhumanism they're
like oh it has so many religious
elements because here you want to
overcome death and you want to live this
life and utopian there's no question
about that but just you know at the very
core of transhumanism is the scientific
method we're not trying to create
anything dogmatic we're always just
trying to accelerate
and science and base things on how we
can create and innovate better and
knowing that we can always do better
we're always going to be wrong it's
never gonna be a matter that
transhumanists are right unless somehow
they become so godlike that they could
their brains or their intelligence span
the universe but more likely here in the
next tens of thousands of years we're
just going to be in organized
intelligence trying to evolve itself and
trying to explore our universe and make
sense of it and make meaning of it we've
been speaking with Zoltan Istvan who's a
former journalist at National Geographic
author of the best-selling science
fiction novel the transhumanist wager
and one of the world's leading
transhumanists really great talking to
you I appreciate your time today
Oh fascinating talk to you too thank you